i've noticed this in america more than
anywhere else i've traveled americans
believe when they watch a movie that
they're watching the people they're
watching and they believe that they are
those characters you know i've run into
people who won't shake my hand
because of a character that i played
[Music]
stand by me
and stand by me uh i got to play ace
merrill all of the characters were so
beautifully defined and and rob reiner
as a director did this amazing thing
with the boys because they were kind of
ranging in ages between kind of 11 and
13. they would play theater games in the
morning
and then they would shoot only in the
afternoon
to cut your shooting schedule in half is
unheard of but he got them to such a
relaxed place that that the bonds that
they started to develop as friends and
as actors was really quite extraordinary
and so my character's sole
responsibility was to be a threat to
these four kids that you would fall in
love with
and
and i went for it
you're dead
you're gonna have to kill me ace
no problem i was i was 17 years old it
was the first job i was ever hired
actually only job i was ever hired for
in the office at the audition and i will
thank rob reiner to the death for that
uh it was one of the most extraordinary
feelings you know but again the
character was just so
well written there was there was no
trying to navigate what he was he was
just you know i don't know if you're
allowed to say but he was an [ __ ] uh
and and as an actor
uh you need to lean into that
we're gonna get you for this
maybe you will and maybe you won't
oh we will
i made great friends casey schmosko
who's in in that gang is still a dear
friend of mine and john cusack worked on
the early parts of that film he and i
became friends corey feldman and i would
end up going to work on lost boys
together river phoenix we had a shared
interest in the guitar we did that
and in fact i think one of the first
songs
i taught him was was stand by me
and that was back when the film was
called the body i don't know if rob
heard that and heard river playing it or
how that
ended up becoming uh the title of the
film but it was the first song
that i had
kind of played with river
the lost boys
when i was doing lost boys i got to play
david he was a much more
well-rounded
bad guy
than ace merrell was in stand by me ace
merrell was almost a cartoon character
whereas david you know becomes friends
with the lead actor you know jason
patrick david as a character is is at
least on paper supposed to be kind of
cool and sexy and and has a girlfriend
and
star
[Music]
i can't beat your bike you don't have to
beat me michael
you just have to try and keep up
developing that character was a very
funny kind of moment because so much of
it was created from
a physical point the look had to be
right the clothes had to be right the
hairstyle had to be right and joel
schumacher as a director was very in
touch with rock and roll and music and
wanted that to be an aspect of this film
wanted it to have that kind of look so i
think all of us on some level started to
try and live out kind of whatever rock
and roll fantasy we might have
joel schumacher wanted me to have white
hair
and and i had very long hair at the time
and he wanted me to keep it and i just
looked like a bad wrestler i looked like
a [ __ ]
it was awful and i thought billy idol
was really cool and i thought he looked
really cool and i still think he looks
really cool his hair was all spiky and
kind of punk up front and so i got that
haircut but i left enough at the back so
i could tell joel schumacher i left it
long and i think kind of accidentally
might have at least been part of a
movement that created maybe one of the
worst hairstyles of all time the mullet
are those maggots
maggots michael
you're eating maggots how do they taste
and i think joel was disappointed that i
had cut my hair but we did five films
together so i think he forgave me
24.
when we were doing 24 i had shot the
pilot and then i went away to do two
other films i wasn't sitting around
waiting to see if it was gonna get
picked up if i gave you a phone number
could you hack in and get all the
internet passwords connected to it sure
if you ever want
and if i didn't have a warrant
it's important
it's pretty important
and the truth is it was just different
enough that i thought
it doesn't really have a chance the
whole idea of everything being filmed in
real time it never been done before we
didn't know if it was going to work and
i would rather stick a darning needle in
my eye than have to work out some of the
logistics that howard gordon and joel
cerneau and and bob cochran did but the
truth is i really liked the character
there was something so nice about not
being
the bad guy there was something so nice
about
this is the guy you want to win
having said that it was painfully
obvious to me out of the gate
that he never would he was never going
to win the odds were too big and he was
just one person and so what i found
really interesting in the process of
developing that character over the first
season
was that there are people in our world
who do jobs that they're never going to
succeed at and yet we would not be here
if it weren't for them i fell in love
with that guy it was just like you know
i can't say that i i'm that guy
but i absolutely admired the character
you know i think all of us felt very
strongly that
that terrible day of 9 11
when
our show started to kind of emulate one
of the great tragedies in american
history
i mean i remember going through weeks of
not wanting to do it anymore and i think
everybody on the show felt the same way
it was like i don't want to i don't i
don't want anything
coming close to
representing
this awful thing that i just watched
happen
having said that the country felt very
differently
even if it was just a television show
and a guy fighting back that's what they
wanted
and that's what we did
get these men to back off and holster
their weapons back off stand down
i often think about how lucky i am to
have had that opportunity i got to work
with a cast and crew over nine seasons
that i will consider family to the day i
die even if i don't get to see them
every day like we used to i have
pictures of my daughter at the beginning
of 24 and grade 6. i have pictures of my
daughter at the end of 24 graduating
from nyu
it was a huge part of mine and my
family's life
and i miss it you know it was an
incredible experience i have learned
that you're just better off not to be
definitive about your answer about
whether you will do something or not do
something i've loved playing that
character uh i do believe the story is
unresolved uh and if something were to
be written
that made sense to me and that i thought
was going to contribute to the franchise
then i would be behind it and even if my
participation in that would be limited i
thought the series that they went to go
do i was i was very excited for all of
them for that too and my involvement
again uh will always be predicated on
what i perceived to be the quality of
the writing howard gordon who was the
show runner for so many years is a
fantastic writer and so
if he is motivated to do something we'll
see what happens
[Music]
a few good men
so a few good men was
an incredible play an incredible script
lieutenant kendrick is the character
that i played he was an interesting
character because
i think when when people have limited
experience they tend to hold on to
things very tightly and so the marine
code of conduct and the bible are two
things
that you could hold on very tightly and
follow to the letter of the law and
still be incredibly wrong and that was
what i used kind of as my defining
moment for that character was that he
had misinterpreted both the bible and
the marine code of conduct in such a way
that it led to someone's
dying commander i believe in god and his
son jesus christ because i do i can say
this
private santiago is dead and that is a
tragedy
but he is dead because he had no code he
is dead because he had no honor
[Music]
and god was watching the story that i'll
always remember from that film was you
know two of the biggest actors in the
world were in the same movie tom cruise
and jack nicholson and and jack
nicholson gives a performance that's
that's iconic and extraordinary
but any actor will tell you that jack
nicholson can't give that performance if
it wasn't for the performance that tom
cruise was giving
it works together and so
the only time i ever saw actors on a day
off come to work
was the two of them squaring off for the
you can't handle the truth scene you
want answers i think i'm entitled you
want answers i don't want the truth you
can't handle the truth
i remember
coming in i had my cup of tea and a
bagel and i sit down somewhere in the
courtroom and i look over and i see you
know bruce willis who's not even working
on the movie he's sitting in the gallery
people are coming from everywhere they
start and the coverage is on jack
nicholson and they do it from top to
bottom the entire scene required a 1200
foot mag back in the days where we used
film and it literally went from end to
end
and he
knocked it out of the park not a slight
hesitation not something like an
uncomfortable moment or trying to kind
of tip your toe into the scene and kind
of see if the water's fine this guy
went for it he took a full-on hank aaron
baseball swing
and he knocked it out of the park i'd
never heard a set that quiet in my life
all the oxygen has just been sucked out
of the room and no one was moving
rob reiner said okay well let's reload
and and then really quickly we'll go
again
and jack smiled and put his head down
and they did it again
and the scene was scheduled for two or
three days of filming and rob reiner
said well it's
never gonna get any better than that so
we wrapped
never seen it happen and i've also never
seen a gallery of cast and crew
uh give an ovation and it was to both of
them and so i was always very proud to
be a part of of that group of actors
a time to kill
in a time to kill it was a hard
character to play it was again joel
schumacher uh at this point we've done
three films or four films together
i got a friend who used to be active
i could give him a call
you do that winston
you tell them boys we need some clan
down here in camp
you know i do remember
i got married uh
just after that film had been finished
and forest whitaker was at my wedding uh
and was friends with me and my wife he
had seen that i was in
uh a time to kill and he's like shook
his head he's like
man you got balls
and i was like why
you don't think people understand it and
he's like
nope
and he was right
resurrect our country from the fires of
racial degradation
and to make white people the sole
masters
of our nation's destiny
and i've noticed this in america more
than anywhere else i've traveled
americans believe when they watch a
movie that they're watching the people
they're watching and they believe that
they are those characters it hasn't
worked out so well with some of the
characters that i played you know i've
run into people
who won't shake my hand because of a
character that i played
i try to explain to them that that the
overall telling of the story the whole
story is what's important not just the
one character
they don't want to hear it i i don't
apologize for the characters that i have
played over the years because
i feel very strongly about the reasons i
chose to do them if you're going to try
and make a movie
about racism and how awful racism is
then you're going to have to show it for
what it is and my character the
character i was asked to play
was the character that was being used to
show you
how horrible how wrong how
backward thinking racism is as an idea
and and even more specifically the clan
uh throughout the united states and i
think that there's a huge responsibility
in playing those characters and playing
those characters correctly
[Music]
dark city
dark city which was directed by alex
poyus was one of my most favorite
experiences that i've ever had as a
person and as an actor i think alex
poyce is a real visionary he wrote
the cartoon version of dark city when he
was 15 years old i did that movie at a
time
when maybe i wasn't
the hottest ticket on the street right
my career was kind of in a questionable
state at best and i met with him in a
hotel and i remember acting out the part
for him in the lobby you know he just
wanted to have a drink with me but i
wasn't going to let it go i was i was
walking out of there with that job and
because i really really wanted it all i
wanted to do in creating the voice was
just the stutter of someone who was so
scared
that that that they couldn't get
everything out because they were scared
that they'd been terribly beaten and
terribly abused and then somehow still
have a spark a wit uh
and trying to convey that in a hotel bar
is not
maybe the easiest thing to do or maybe
the brightest call but i think
what he got from it was
that i would do anything
this one is still long
what is it
the recollections of a great lover
a catalog of conquests
i loved that character
i mean
one of the worst hairstyles of all time
and i wore that hairstyle for four
months with pride you know for the right
to do that part
[Music]
designated survivor
in designated survivor i play tom
kirkman i have to say that that
character is probably
closer to me as a person than any other
character that i've played and it's by
design
i think as
we get older we become hopefully more
comfortable in our skin
tom kirkman as the president was was
never pretending that he knew everything
or that he was the smartest he was
thrust in a position
out of terrible tragedy
and all he says is i'm gonna do my best
i love that about that character just
look we're all trying to navigate this
thing called life
and
it's not easy for anyone i don't care
what you have and what you think
i felt that there was a humanity in tom
kirkman that
understood that about all people
you really think i should step down
[Music]
i
do
you may be right
the look of everything is going to have
an impact it's going to always be much
easier to work in a beautiful set that
represents the oval office in the white
house than it is to do it with green
screen and sit in an odd fake chair and
all of that stuff so so your
surroundings have a very profound impact
but at the root of all of it is the
writing it's going to be the story lines
and the words
that rule the day
[Music]
the first lady
well i don't play a lady
the first lady is is actually one of my
favorite projects that i've ever been a
part of it chronicles the lives of three
first ladies viola davis
plays michelle obama michelle pfeiffer
plays betty ford and jillian anderson
plays eleanor roosevelt and i play
franklin roosevelt to her eleanor and
it's told from the perspective of these
three women it's not told from the men's
point of view so this is about how they
changed the office of the first lady in
their time
and how they affected
their presidential husbands
is it true
that i am not to have a proper job in
your administration please stop
listening to louie well give me
something else to hear
fine
i am not entirely comfortable
nobody else is getting two appointments
i'm not asking for two appointments
i'll think about it i would be asked
when doing designated survivor who is my
favorite american president and and i
would say fdr and fdr primarily because
he was dealing with a great depression
he was dealing with the dust bowl then
dealt with world war ii
he had very difficult decisions to make
during his presidency and this is where
i think eleanor roosevelt was so
influential that she was his moral
compass
doesn't mean he always followed it but
she certainly made his life complicated
when he didn't
and i think that's a good partnership
playing fdr was the first time i had
been asked to play
a real character a person that existed
for me i started with the voice and the
voice was the most important his radio
address you know on december 7th 1941 is
is something that every child has heard
in school he was a president that
spanned uh four terms he died early in
his fourth term so then the physicality
of when he was a younger man to when he
was an older man and he changed
dynamically because of polio all
challenges but all really exciting i
mean this is the kind of thing certainly
any actor that i know that i am friends
with that knows i got to play that
character is jealous
the contractor
chris pine and ben foster both did
arguably my favorite film of the decade
which was hell or high water i think
they're the closest duo that i've seen
that kind of reminds me of
robert redford and paul newman just the
way they act together the way they
interact together is really special
my character uh
wants a b c and d and he'll do e
and f to get it we gave them our minds
our bodies and our spirit
and they chewed us up and spit us out
left us with fear rage uncertainty
disillusionment a sense of abandonment
betrayal
and finally
self-loathing and guilt
as if somehow
everything that happened to us was our
own goddamn fault
it's a very sad story where an an older
person manipulates a younger person
to get what they want that's what the
audience person is going to have to
challenge themselves with when they
watch that movie
i don't know anyone who thinks getting
old is great but there are some serious
benefits and one of them is that
i believe now i have a sense of security
in my thought process and how i approach
storytelling in a way that i absolutely
did not have when i was a younger person
i actually go to work
with
all of the excitement a young person
might have but without all of the fear